[music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
[music] regarding health or income. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to [music] share the teachings
of a founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor [music] of Science in Plant and
Soil Sciences, Doctor of Veterary
Medicine, Ford Post-Do and Pathology,
Naturopathic Doctor.
>> [music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. [music]
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual. Results
vary and may not be typical. We do not
make any claims [music] regarding health
or income. As an empowered individual,
you do have options available. We are
honored to continue to [music] share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel
Wallik, Bachelor [music] of Science in
Plant and Soil Sciences, Doctor of
Veterary Medicine, Ford Post-Do and
Pathology, Naturopathic Doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences
[music] of the individual. Results vary
and may not be typical. We do not make
any claims regarding [music] health or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics, [music]
Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor of Science
in Plant and soil sciences, doctor of
veterary medicine, four post-doates in
pathology, naturopathic doctor.
Hello everybody and welcome back to
Daily with Doc and Becca. I'm your host,
Becca Dukes. And as a certified holistic
health coach, as a certified
naturopathic practitioner, and the host
and producer of this show, I am excited
that we are able to educate, empower,
and equip people to live healthier,
stronger lives. So today's conversation
is going to be one that I think that
every leader, parent, coach, business
owner, and lifelong learner needs to
hear. So, if you can think of anybody
that falls into one of those different
categories, make sure that you are
liking, subscribing, and sharing the
this Daily with Doc and Becca show with
those that you know and love who are
leaders, parents, coaches, business
owners, and lifelong learners. So
folks, also if you were shared this
program by somebody specific, they cared
enough about you to share this program,
make sure that you get back with them as
they are your number one point of
contact. If you have any questions in
regards to things that you hear on
today's show, if you found us all on
your own and you do have questions and
want to to get more information, I do
have a call team standing by at
855-9493377.
Again, that's for people that are not
already working with somebody and found
us all on your own. you. This program is
being sponsored by dailywithdoc.com
and if you uh want to get like good
foods bad foods list or any of our
previous programming including helpful
articles you can go to dailywithdoc.com.
Make sure that you sign up for our
newsletter and if you're on any of the
different platforms let us know where
you're joining us from.
Today's conversation is one that I
think, like I said, every leader,
parent, coach, business owner, and
lifelong learner needs to hear. Joining
us today is our good friend Jill Huelet,
the brain fitness expert, speaker,
educator, and wellness advocate who has
spent years helping people understand
how to strengthen the brain to improve
focus, resilience, communication, and
performance. So today we're going to be
diving into the exciting topic of brain
fitness to lead and motivate yourself
and others because leadership doesn't
begin with managing people. It begins
begins with managing ourselves.
So how do we stay motivated? How do we
adapt under stress? How do we influence
and inspire others while continuing to
grow ourselves?
Jill is going to be sharing some of that
information with us today as our brains
are capable of learning, changing, and
developing throughout our lives. So,
when we're intentionally strengthening
folks,
we can become better leaders at home, in
business, and in our communities. So,
please help me. Welcome to Daily with
Doc and Becca Jill Helet. Hello Jill.
Welcome back. Fitness, brain fitness
expert. Um we're super excited as today
we are going to be, you know, talking
about brain fitness for leadership.
And I love the fact that you've also got
a story to share of how this works and
has helped somebody you know.
>> Absolutely. I'm happy to be here with
you all. Thank you, Becca, and that
wonderful warm introduction and really
getting people understanding why brain
fitness is so important and how all
leadership and motivation starts with
ourselves. It starts within and impacts
every area of our life. So, I'm really
excited to talk about this.
>> It, you know, it really does influence
all areas of life. And
I was at the grocery store this morning
and this sweet, sweet lady kept, you
know, forgetting which cart was hers
even though she had her big purse in it
and and, you know, going to different
carts and just kind of scattered. And
it's like, sweetie, life's too short.
just relax
>> and don't forget to take your essential
fatty acids.
>> But but you know
>> more clearly. Absolutely. Yes.
>> Yeah. So nut nutrition is a part of it
>> but you're going to be sharing more
about it with us today.
>> Yeah. Yes. I'm happy to. I'm really
happy to, you know, for people who are
new to this concept, maybe I could
start, if it's okay with you, with what
brain fitness is in general and and that
can be the launching point for the rest
of the conversation.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Great. Great. Well, brain fitness
starts off with the awareness, the
awareness that we can change, improve,
heal, develop, and optimize our brain at
every age and stage of life. And I have
this expandable sphere. So I like to
show people that we can go from using a
small portion of our brain to our whole
brain potential. And this is exciting
because I mean it's our responsibility
but it's also our opportunity to make
that shift into greater potential,
greater resources. Uh we call this our
whole brain dynamic. And uh so that's
step one in brain fitness of if I was to
describe what brain fitness is, I like
to describe it in three components. So
that's the first one, the awareness that
you can do that. The second component is
that it's based on userfriendly
neuroscience. So, this is not complex
information, but it is science-based and
it's accessible to pretty much anyone
from like grade six upward, you know, uh
with uh that kind of educational
background. It's really it really is
accessible to everybody because it's
applicable to daily life issues and
needs. So, step two is that userfriendly
neuroscience. It's all research and
sciencebacked. And again, we're we're
also living on the planet at a time when
more and more information is coming out.
But brain fitness takes that and makes
it into simple relatable terms. And then
the third step of the three components
are the strategies. It's what we do, our
habits, the tools, the techniques, the
activities that we incorporate into our
daily lives to create our fit brain and
really really, you know, activate our
brain fitness. But I also like to say
that's life fitness because when we have
a fit brain, we also have a more fit
life because that ripples out into all
areas. Our career, our health, our
relationships, our our our um just our
hobbies. and extracurricular activities
into everything.
>> So, how does this connect to leadership
and motivation?
>> Ah, right. So, we're going into a
specific topic here. And that's what I
do. I always customize this material for
the group I'm working with. And in this
particular session, we thought this
would be a really useful uh um focus for
us because really most people, I would
say, want to get the most out of their
lives. They want to live healthy lives.
They want to live healthier lives. They
want to potentially improve their lives.
And if that's they're going to do that,
they it requires leadership and
motivation. Um so leadership and
motivation directly connect with our
brain functioning right because we have
something called these executive
functions this higher order part of our
brain and it is the it's actually
located in our neoortex the new area of
our brain and it's what gives us the
human advantage um because it allows us
to do things like plan strategize
problem solve, make decisions, be
creative, self-manage,
uh self-regulate, set goals and move
towards them effectively.
And this is different from other uh
mammals. Um we have a large number of
neurons in this area and they are
equipped to perform these tasks
typically. Um, but we're not always able
to access those higher order functions.
Even though we might be in a classroom
where it's required of us or in a weight
workplace where it's expected of us, we
don't always we aren't always able to
get to that higher part of our brain or
use it optimally. And that's where brain
fitness comes in. It shows us how what
we need to do in order to ensure that we
have access to these amazing executive
functions which allow us to lead our
lives uh powerfully, strategically,
efficiently, productively, you know, and
and all that all that is really exciting
and possible.
However, uh if we are not if we are
dealing with stress, we are in a more
limited portion of our brain, right?
We're not in that whole brain dynamic
where we have access to those executive
functions. And so beneath the executive
functions is the mamleian part of the
brain. It's the lyic system. And it is
the part of our brain that is connected
to our emotions, our connections with
others, our ability to bond, our
feelings and our motivation. And if we
are busy fighting stressors in our life,
we are not able to move to that higher
part of our brain. Instead, we shut down
into survival mode because our brain's
top priority um above and beyond
anything else is our survival. If we're
not here on the planet, nothing else
matters anyway. So, it wants to keep us
alive. So the moment we are dealing with
things like too many things to do like
look an upcoming deadline that we're
afraid we're not going to uh we're not
going to reach or we're dealing with
frustrations and disappointments because
we don't like the behaviors of others
and we feel it's impacting us or we're
simply dehydrated
uh or lacking in sleep or not full uh
filled up in proper nutrition.
our system knows that and our system
will go into a survival state whereby we
can't access those higher order
functions that um we we really need to
lead and live effectively and optimally.
>> You know, it's amazing how so many
people don't realize how the emotion
affects their health and well-being.
Can can you expound upon that just a
little bit more?
>> Yeah, absolutely. So in brain fitness,
we look at these three different
dimensions, the physical, the emotional,
and the mental. And we have activities
and strategies to support each area. And
at the end of our talk, we're actually
going to go through some um but the idea
is that we can't all emotions are meant
to eb and flow. And we think of the word
emotion, energy in motion. And all
feelings typically have a beginning, a
middle, and an end. But our system can
get stuck in a certain mode, right? If
we are not attending to the stressor or
and that can mean anything from having a
mindset shift, setting a boundary,
communicating a need, you know, the the
list goes on. But if we are not managing
it or dealing with it, it can have this
underlying effect and impact and be a
distraction. So, we're in what's called
a chronic stress state. something is
constantly going on behind the scenes
that is uh causing strain, causing
tension, causing causing stress. And a
lot of that a lot of that is connected
to our emotions because a lot of people
don't weren't taught how to handle their
emotions, how to express their emotions,
to feel comfortable with emotions. So, I
mean, we're we have a short time
together. There's so this is such a vast
topic but I will say that that is one of
the main three dimensions that we uh we
look at in brain fitness and we teach
people how to become aware of and then
our emotions but have more emotional
balance, more emotional vitality. And we
can be working with emotional emotions
that are more healthy for us like joy,
happiness, peace, calm rather than the
frustration, anger, disappointment,
grief. All of these emotions are
welcome. Of course, we we we're having
this human experience. We need to
experience the full gamut of human
emotions. But the issue is is when we
are stuck in replay in in a loop in an
emotion that is not serving us and we
are not processing it effectively. So
that will impede again our ability to
access these executive functions which
also includes our ability to focus and
decision make and really really engage
in our lives from a place of inner
leadership.
>> Right? because that's where that's where
it really begins.
>> Wow.
As you're going through all these
different things, I'm like doing a
replay in my life, you know, doing this
this whole scanning what's going on. I
was like, "Yep, yep, yep." Because
you're right on. You're absolutely
absolutely right on. So tell us a little
bit about your sister's story
>> and how it relates to today's topic.
>> And I I will go into that. You just made
me think about as you're thinking about
your experience, I think I'll just put
it out there to those who are listening
to think in your own lives where
something like this has happened where
you have this great plan in mind. Okay,
your executive functions, you've got a
plan, you're starting to execute.
Executive functions is the taking
action, the executing on a plan. And
then all of a sudden it gets hijacked.
And what we how we can look at this just
before I share my sister's story is
sister's story [laughter]
is is by a a rider and a horse. The
executive functions would be the the
rider on top of a horse. The horse would
be representing our lyic system,
emotional cognitive brain. And so the
higher part of our brain can guide
the horse. The rider can guide the
horse. But we know if that horse gets
spooked,
what will happen? The horse will buck.
It will run off. It will what it will it
will react. And the rider can't do much
about that. So the rider needs to find
out how to work with the horse so they
work together as a team. So another part
of this brain fitness is not about
judging part of oursel. It's how to work
with these these unintegrated feelings
or these these these past issues that we
haven't resolved and so that we can be
more integrated and and a available
emotionally available in the present
moment. for what we're dealing with. So
those executive functions, the
leadership part can then work in a
healthy way with the motivational part,
right? Because our motivation comes from
those emotions. Our motivation to run
away from danger or a motivation to
pursue pleasure, right? It it's a
motivation. It's getting us moving.
Those are our happy neurochemicals. our
dopamine, our our oxytocin, our
serotonin, our endorphins, all of those
neurochemicals are what are here to
motivate us to take action. But the
question is, are we constantly taking
action or and are we kind of stuck in a
place where we're not able to take
action or taking action that is working
against ourselves and against others or
are we working in harmony? Are we
working in alignment? Are we working in
a place of more balance? And that's
where we can lead more effectively or or
effectively.
Wonderful. Wonderful. So, all right. You
know, I I remember the first time you
and I spoke. You know, you've had so
many different testimonies. You had your
mom's testimony. You had your sister's
testimony yourself. And today
topic relate your sister's testimony
fits right in.
>> Yeah.
>> So would you go ahead and share that?
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. So my sister the
the main reason why I associate this
with leadership and motivation is that
she was a very exceptional athlete as a
as a youngster as an adolescent. Okay.
And that was she really led teams. She
was on an international track team. She
played rep baseball. And when you're
playing a highle sport, you need to be a
leader, right? Because you're constantly
working on yourself. Plus, you're you're
also looking at out working towards
certain outcomes, whether it's just
yourself, it's if it's an independent
sport or with others, if you're on a
team. And so there and and you're always
fine-tuning. You're always looking how
to be better, how to be faster, how to
be stronger, how to be quicker. And we
can we can relate that to to life the
life experience, right? And
self-improvement just to in any area of
life or any any role that we have. But
for her, this story connects to her
being an athlete. Now, to do this story
justice, we need to back up even further
to my mom. And I've referred to part of
my mom's story before and on uh prior
interviews with you, but we haven't
cover I don't think we covered this
part. And this relates directly to
Angie. So my mom many years ago in the
70s had three children within a 5year
span.
and she did not realize at the time that
each time she had a child, you know,
grew them, birthe them, nursed them. Um,
she was losing essential nutrients.
Okay? And so I was the firstborn. She
had me. Then three years later, she had
my middle sister, her middle sister, my
middle sister, Dena, her second child.
And then she had Angie, who this story
is about, a year and a half after that.
And so, um,
my mom had enough nutrition to bring
Angie to term.
So, we didn't know that there was any
issue going on. She had the full nine
months. But once she birthed Angie, she
had a lot of allergies.
Allergies set in and it was really
difficult. She had three young kids. She
couldn't breathe, which meant she
couldn't think properly. She couldn't
function as easily, and she couldn't
sleep at night. And this was going
>> was this your mom that had the allergies
or Angie?
>> Um, great question. My mom. My mom. So,
this was the first part of the journey
where something was going on, but we
didn't connect the dots yet.
>> So, great clarity. So, it's my mom who's
dealing with these um this health issue.
And so she was going to the doctor and
he was giving her various nose sprays
and she was taking all these different
over-the-counter allergy medications,
but nothing was working. She was So 7
months later, after 7 months of dealing
with this, she decides that she's going
to go and see the chiropractor to get an
adjustment to see if that will help
alleviate some of the these issues and
uh help her breathe better. And when she
was there, thankfully this chiropractor
was studying to be a naturopath. And so
he was very aware of nutrition and
nutritional supplementation and
deficiencies. And so he basically and
wisely said to my mom, Helen, you you've
just had your third child. You nurse
them. You're you've been nursing them
all. Um you are deficient and these
allergies are connected to a nutritional
deficiency, especially minerals. we need
to get you on a mineral supplement. So,
they did and within less than two weeks,
her allergies are gone and she's feeling
energized and she has this mental
clarity and she can lead her live
effectively. It's hard to be, you know,
lead your life and be motivated when you
can't breathe and you're not getting
enough sleep and there's a ripple
effect, right? So, that that's that was
that part of the story. Now, she didn't
know to continue taking the minerals
indefinitely, not realizing that this
isn't something you stop taking. This
these are the nutrients that are
supposed to be in your food, but our
food is lacking. So, you have to invest
in your health and take these
proactively so that you can stay healthy
long term. Well, currently and long
term. So, but she was feeling she took
them for a while and then got off them.
She did also didn't realize uh that
there was an opportunity to give them to
the whole family. So none of this
clicked in at that time.
Now fast forward a few years. Angie's be
is a youngster and there's we're
noticing that she is like this amazing
athlete and she by by the age of five
she was in competitive roller skating.
Uh when if she put her on a so soccer
field, she like outrun all the kids. No
one could keep up. That put her into
track and field. And here she is, you
know, training, practicing, sweating.
Then she went on to play many years of
rep baseball. And so she's doing all
this and we just think this is great.
Being active is healthy. Playing sports,
it's fun. And and you learn a lot of
wonderful skills as we said earlier,
playing a sport. Um, and so that that
was we just thought that's normal or
that's great that she's doing that and
didn't think anything though of the
nutrition or supplement supplementing
side. So then what happened is as Angie
was getting a little bit older, there
were some things that were happening
that we didn't connect to deficiency
but in but we learned after were d were
the direct correlation. And for example,
she out of the three of us was getting
the most having the most cavities yet we
were eating all the same. She was having
more teeth issues. Why was she having
that and not us, right? She would have
more cravings. Cravings for sugar than
the rest of us. She started cribbing.
She would literally bite on things. Like
Doc Wallik would say, when a animal is
looking for more nutrients, it will bite
on, you know, trees and fences and
things to because it's looking for
nutrition. So, she would start to do
that and she would actually literally
run in her sleep. So, we thought that
she was just we made a joke that she was
just training 24/7, but actually
learning later all of these were signs
of nutritional deficiencies.
especially um there was concern but not
again correlating that this was due to
nutrition but that by grade 8 she
started to have asthma and she was put
on an inhaler.
And at this point because this was
having such an impact these things on
her physical health that it was starting
to be noticed in her performance. And so
the coaches and trainers were saying
things like she just needs to practice
more. we just she just needs to train
harder. She needs to like get her brain
her mind in the game. But the reality is
this had nothing to do with her her
skill level, her capabilities or her
motivation
because she naturally was a leader on
the field. It came to the fact that she
was not equipped. Her system was
struggling. Her system was um weakening
because it didn't have the resources
that it needed. So now she goes into
high school and she's starting to have
injuries that aren't healing.
And she even had a tubing incident when
she was out on a lake and it caused such
issues with her hips that for a long
time after she didn't have regular
mobility and her hips were so so sore
she could barely touch them. Then she
ended up pulling her ankle and um it was
a significant issue with her ankle to
the point where I guess she she had to
be in a cast for three months. And
afterwards the during that time and
after the he the ankle did not heal so
it affected her sports and she when she
she was a back catcher in baseball. So
rather than fully being able to squat
she had to hold one leg out to the side.
So here she is struggling with playing
sports, the thing she loves, the thing
that she was the best at. And it was her
outlet. It was her joy. And ultimately
the doctors couldn't do anything. They
were basically like, "Hey, your body is
just going through this for whatever
reason. You know, it's random. This
happens to some people and not others,
but hey, when you're of age, we can give
you a hip replacement." Because she had,
you know, she was still dealing with the
the hip issue. And so here she is, you
know, in 17 now going on 18 years of age
and basically having to give up on her
sports like she had to she had to pull
back from playing because it was just
taking too much of a toll.
Thankfully, now the story goes on to the
positive side and the resolution.
In her mid20s is when our family had met
Doc Wallik, which is another fantastic
story and that was shared in a prior
interview. So people can check it out
there. Um, but basically it was meant to
be and we came across Dog Wallik and not
only did he turn my mom's health around
because by this time when Angie's 25, my
mom's in her late 50s and she's having
um health issues. She's having uh
decline and the doctors are telling
there there's nothing that can be done
for her either. So my mom gets on to Doc
Wallik's advice, recommends nutritional
changes, dietary changes, you know, take
take the eat the good foods, take out
the bad foods, and then supplement with
the 90 and then other strategic
supplements.
And so Angie got on the program, too,
and amazing results. Amazing. Her body
just started to heal because it had the
nutrition it needed. and she remembers
the day when she was actually doing yoga
and she could all of a sudden fully
stretch and she could actually put her
foot fully down in a downward dog which
she couldn't do before because she had
lost her range of motion. And it was
just like her body was coming back to
her and she was able to be active again.
And this of course affects your mood
because now you realize you're not
falling apart. you're actually
strengthening and building and you can
do the things you enjoy and love and you
can participate and engage. And so that
that was basically her story and it
continues on today. Uh you know she's uh
very active. Her and her husband are
outdoorsy people. They ski, they
snowboard. Uh she's in the Newf Finland
tourism commercial running in with
snowshoes with her dog. I mean, and and
it really is it's it's thanks to Doc
Wallik that our whole family has
benefited, but in particular, you heard
certain family members stories, and this
one's Angie, and she would not be in the
state that she's in if it wasn't for
finding out about um Doc Wallik's
research and his program and and his
guidance.
That's awesome.
And and I know how disheartening it is
to be so young
and then to have that surgery word come
up
because they wanted to do surgery on my
knees when I was 15. They wanted to to
go in and scrape because I had all this
buildup and I I'm like I'm so glad my
mom was not for it. So glad.
>> Oh, absolutely. But people don't know
their options. They think that that is
the only option. They don't know
healing, recovery, repair, reversal is a
thing. And and and years later, like our
cells are just waiting. It's not like
they've turned off their desire to be
healthy. They're they're just waiting.
They're on pause waiting to be given the
right um fuel, the right environment to
actually self-correct and to heal and to
rebuild. And it's just such a beautiful
thing. And that's why what you're doing,
you and your team and getting these
messages out there, these stories, these
real life stories are it's so important
because on some way there there's people
listening who can relate. They they have
kids who are playing sports who they
realize this doesn't make sense to keep
pushing the kids without fuel them
fueling them properly, but they don't
know how to do it. Or their child is
having injuries, more and more injuries,
and not recovering. And this is a red
flag. something is wrong here. They
don't know what to do about it. And then
eventually left unattended into
adulthood,
this becomes a major case of chronic
degenerative disease. And we know that
that is plaguing the world, especially
here in Canada and the US and North
America. We have
staggering numbers of chronic
degenerative disease. And we It's crazy
because we can do something about it. It
doesn't have to be that way.
>> And and a message to the young folks
who are active and in pain but don't
want to disappoint their parents so they
keep going.
It's where I was.
You don't have to be in pain.
Pain does not have to be part of your
life.
nutritional program. Get with the person
that shared this program with you.
Parents, if you've got kids, you think
maybe that their ability to to perform
and be the athlete that they want to be
is being hindered by something, even if
they're not expressing the pain.
Nutrition is going to really make a huge
difference.
>> So, well said. So well said. And Becca,
can I add into that that it's yes on on
the sports playing field. It's also in
the classroom because that's the other
part of brain fitness. It's it's the
physical side. It's those those
activities, our ability to perform and
engage and communicate and hand eye
coordination and you know be have speed
and agility and balance and all those
things. those directly correlate to our
executive functions and our ability to
focus um comprehend,
communicate, organize, um understand
things in a classroom setting. And so
when kids are struggling, whether it's
on the playing field, they're just not
motivated or they say they're in
discomfort or pain, listen to it because
there's something going on in the
classroom. if they're struggling,
they're having a hard time sitting still
focusing. This is not a rolin
deficiency, right? This is not this is
not about, you know, a mental you need a
mental health uh it's usually it's not
about a mental health issue. It's about
their motivation for them feeling
capable to do what is being asked of
them. But something there's a
disconnect. And so we need to find out
what that disconnect is. And we can use
our body by fueling it properly, right?
By giving it the essential nutrients,
proper hydration, proper food, proper
supplements, all of a sudden the child
can now think better and more clearly in
the classroom as well. Uh there's a book
out there that I always love the name is
your child's brain starving and we often
think about feeding the body but not
realizing whatever we feed our body,
we're also feeding our brain as well.
So yeah, it's like what is what is our
brain and body not getting that it needs
so it can per perform these daily tasks
and improve
a and just to add to that you know we
don't need to have a label given
to start feeding the body
we don't have to have those symptoms
coming
everybody needs it
there is nobody body. Nobody on God's
green earth that does not need
nutrition.
So the earlier we start them, the easier
it's going to be on them later in life
because that those things that they say
are oh just part of being older. the
brain fog, the inability to to focus,
the discomforts here and there, the lack
of flexibility.
That's not just part of getting older.
>> No, absolutely not. Well said. Well
said. And the the lack of um minerals in
our soil only continues, right? We know
our our soils deplete and so but it's
worse for generations today. Like the
food kids are eating did not our
grandparents did not eat and our
grandparents had access to foods that
did were more nutrientdense than the
foods available. So with the amount of
packaged processed fast foods,
especially families that are busy on the
go, and I get it, parents have a lot on
their plates. They are juggling a lot of
responsibilities and schedules. And if
their kids are athletes, that is busy.
like you're going from one diamond to
the next, one practice to the next, and
it's hard to keep up. So, what happens
is just like throw this in your mouth or
we'll get go through the drive-thru. And
the reality is is that with some
planning, you can have some of the best
nature's food, fruits, vegetables,
healthy proteins, make it easy, don't
have to have fancy recipes, and then
take the supplements morning and night.
Take the energy drinks throughout the
day. What I love about uh Doc Wallik is
there's so many um liquid formulas that
you can, you know, put in add to your
water bottle or mix with water, add
extra minerals in and you know, you're
sipping that throughout the course of
the day. And it will also help you to
stay hydrated and that can replace the
juices, the pops, the things that um
kids are typically having because again,
they're not being given the option. But
once given the option, the body the body
likes it. like these ta these products
taste good anyway, but your body starts
to crave it because you know it's what
you need.
>> Yeah. And unless you've you've tried it,
you don't know. And so many of the the
sports drinks or the quote unquote
protein bars, they have chemicals and
sugar in them that it creates
inflammation.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
>> Yeah. Yeah. This is this is top quality,
certified organic, all like pure natural
from the earth, right? And our cells
will recognize it and put it to use. And
that's why Beck and you see it all the
time and so do we. People have a fast
turnaround because the body puts it to
use right away. It's what your cells
want to be fed and they're just waiting
to be given this proper fuel.
So folks, don't wait until you're in
such a depleted state that your body's
completely falling apart before deciding
to start feeding the body and giving the
body a complete nutritional program.
U Bruce out on YouTube, he says, "Great
story. Minerals and nutrients or a hip
replacement. You can't deny
testimonials." You're absolutely right,
Bruce, who has his own testimony will
hear someday. So, [snorts]
uh,
>> thank you,
>> Jill.
>> Yeah.
>> What are some of the strategies that we
can use to support our ability to lead
and motivate ourselves and others to do
better?
>> So, there are there are countless things
that we can ultimately do. And in our
brain fitness programs, we we cover
different activities based on the amount
of time we have with the group and what
their goals are. But in there are
certain things that are just universally
beneficial, right? So I like to talk
about those regardless of age or stage
of life or what what it is you're trying
to achieve. And the first thing is I'm
going to say that we need to uh take out
the bad food and put in the good food.
And I think that people can contact you
back up for that list. uh they can
contact me as well. Um but basically we
need to take out the things that are
going to aggravate our system and cause
inflammation and put in the healthy
foods that have all the vitamins,
minerals, fibers, um proteins, all the
macronutrients that we that we need that
we require.
Then we need to supplement properly and
we are big fans of starting with the
minerals. But of course the the 90
essential nutrients are the you know the
entire package and that is the most
recommended place to start if a person
can. It has the vitamins, minerals,
amino acids and essential fatty acids
and the ones that Doc Wallik has proven
that our cells need to function
currently and long term. So you get the
right macronutrients, you get the right
micronutrients into your into your body,
therefore to your brain. Um, and then
the next tip is to stay hydrated. Sip
water throughout the course of your day.
It's very very important.
And then we could do some specific brain
fitness strategies starting with
something really easy, which is
breathing. And I like to give a reminder
on this because it's something we can
practice anywhere, anytime. All you need
to do is just remember to adjust your
breathing and do it intentionally with a
big inhale through your nose
and then an exhale through your mouth.
Inhale through your nose
and exhale through your mouth.
And as you're doing this, I invite you
to embody that breathing. So that you're
actually creating a sense of relaxation
by doing this and the sense of
energizing effect too because you're
sending all this wonderful oxygen to
these these neurons, these brain cells
on the inhale.
And then when you release and let go,
your body can also tap into that
parasympathetic respon that response
that rest and digest response. So in
inhale
and exhale.
Okay, great. So once you've done that
several times um and you can do it as
focus on it as long as you want. It's it
can become like a mini meditation and
it's great for mindfulness bringing you
back into the present moment. Of course
we need ourselves need this oxygen and
oftentimes we're going around stressed
and busy and forgetting to breathe
properly or deeply. So practicing this
as often as possible is is really
important. And as far as leadership and
motivation, again to come back from
earlier in the conversation, when we're
in stress, we're not able to think
clearly. We can't access those executive
functions. And simply drinking some
water and breathing deeply will allow us
to reconnect to that that whole brain,
our whole brain resources. So right away
we're moving into that that better
state. And then you could do something
uh this this is to move us into
coherence. So our thoughts, our feelings
and actions are working together as a
team coherently. What you're going to do
is take one hand and put it just cover
your forehead and you're when you do
that you're you're placing your hand on
top of your neurovvascular points and
what you're doing is you're encouraging
blood flow up to this um the executive
function area here this frontal lobe. So
that's the first part and interestingly
enough the pressure points located where
you're holding are also connected to the
stomach meridian. So it actually can
help calm any anxiety, any butterflies.
So just this activity alone is
wonderful. If you want to add to it, you
can put your other hand on your heart.
And when you do this, what you're doing
is you're creating a heart brain
connection. And so while you hold these
two positions, you can just take some
nice deep breaths.
And I'll just let you know that there
are brain cells in your heart. And more
messages move from your heart to your
brain than the other way around. So this
is a wonderful way to get heart centered
to calm our emotions
to calm our body and to calm our mind
actually and bring everything back into
that aligned coherent state. So you hold
this for 30 seconds to a minute and then
you can switch over and do the other
side. Um, so people, you'll notice as
you do it, a change is happening. So pay
attention and you might after 30 seconds
say, "I've had enough." You might want
to hold it longer. The great thing is,
too, if you're having a hard time
falling asleep, you can do it while
you're laying in bed. It will help calm
you so you can process any unintegrated
feelings and thoughts so you can get
into a sleep ready state. So there's
that. And then what will I share? Um,
another great activity, we haven't
talked about this before, but is
visualizing because you can activate the
same neuropathways that would be
actually used to perform those
particular activities simply by thinking
about it. And so, take a moment every
day maybe to start your day. This is a
wonderful leadership and motivation um
technique because it really allows you
to en get connected with through vision
envisioning how you want your day to go,
how you want to show up. Now, of course,
we know life always is going to change.
we have plan A and there's going to be
plan B and that's fine but we're setting
into motion
um some neural pathways connecting with
neural pathways so that we can move more
closely to our desired plans and goals
right and this as simple as just closing
your eyes sitting in a comfortable
position and imagining
yourself feeling happy
feeling healthy and energized ized and
and see yourself performing different
tasks whether it's driving to work,
sitting at your desk, giving a
presentation,
having conversations
with your colleagues, with your staff,
with your friends, with your clients,
with your customers, whoever it is, and
see and feel how you would like that to
be. Are you having fun? Are you being
clear? are you feeling efficient and
productive? And you can bring that you
can encourage that energy to come online
so that you can actually um start to
create your outcomes before you actually
start to go into your day. So you've
like set that in motion.
And then last but not least, as one more
activity to wrap it up, which we've
covered before, but I'm going to cover
again because it's so important to get
the left and right brain hemispheres
working together as a team, our logic
and our creative sides. You can do the
movement of one hand, taking one hand
across your body to your opposite leg,
and then switching back and forth.
And when you do this, you're turning
your upper body, so you're getting that
cerebral spinal fluid moving. And when
we've been sitting too long, our brain
becomes goes into screen saver mode. It
becomes less engaged. So by moving the
body, you're reactivating your brain.
You're getting uh oxygen and blood flow
and nutrients to the brain as well. And
by turning side to side and crossing
over that midline, you're getting the
logic and creative sides of your brain
working together as a team. uh you might
want to do this uh standing up which
requires balance which is actually has
even further benefit. I actually
encourage you to do it standing up and
doing it slowly because as you switch
from leg to leg it's simply walking on
the spot your brain will be engaged even
further. So those are some activities
you can do. Um, I hope that you have
fun. Have fun with it and see the
difference and 30 seconds to a minute
really will start to have a really great
impact. Just do it consistently.
>> Wonderful. Wonderful. Thank you so much,
Jill. So, there is one thing that
happened last week and I'm very
disappointed that I did not
um I was not aware of it and I should
have been because if I read my email, I
would know. But we missed an event that
you did, a webinar
that you did on the 29th.
Do you have any more coming up? Any on
your schedule that we would be able to
invite people to or better yet send them
to your website so that they can sign up
for your newsletter?
>> Yes, thank you for asking. Yes, I had a
brain fitness for better results webinar
and we had a great response to that. Uh,
and that was yeah, last Friday. But I'm
going to be I do offer these every so
often. So, I'd be happy for people to go
to my website at jillhwletit.com.
It's my firstnamel lastname.com
and sign up for the newsletter and
receive these updates and these
invitations. And, uh, those are free
webinars. Uh, they're fun. We cover a
lot of userfriendly neuroscience as
always and then strategies people can
implement and also on my website at the
top there's access to the free brain
guide as well for those who are
interested and I welcome people to reach
out and be in touch through email or
social media.
Awesome. So folks, Jill Hwlet, hwle
t.com.
Make sure that you go there, sign up for
her newsletter, get that free ebook she
just spoke about, and get connected
so that you can not just make sure your
body is getting the nutrition and
activities that it needs, but your brain
has the right fitness as well.
Well, Jill, um, if you have time, so if
anybody has any questions or comments,
go ahead put raise your hand. You can
also put them in the chat as we do have
people on all the different platforms
um watching the chat and here in the
live Zoom which folks if you'd like to
join us live we're here Wednesday
from 12 to 1:00 p.m. Pacific, 1:2
Mountain, 2 to 3 Central, 3 to 4
Eastern. And if you're in any other time
zone, please ask your favorite browser
or AI tool what time it is in your time
zone at
12:00 p.m. Pacific or 300 p.m. Eastern,
your choice. Um Marilyn, before Marilyn
unmutes and comes on screen with us, I
just want to remind everything that this
program is for educational purposes
only. So many things are common sense.
But folks, this does not take the place
of your primary care physician, nor does
it mean meant to treat, diagnose or cure
any disease.
But what Dr. Wallik has shown us through
the science of epigenetics is there are
no genetic transferred diseases.
There's over 900 different symptoms
associated with nutritional deficiency.
So chances are what you are experiencing
is linked to that nutrition part. So go
ahead and get back with a person that
shared this program with you. If there's
no one to thank, go to our website,
dailywithdoc.com.
You're going to find the good foods bad
foods list there. Sign up again for our
email list. And if you'd like to speak
to a certified holistic health coach and
you're not working with somebody,
855-9493377.
And one of those coaches,
Marilyn, go ahead and unmute yourself.
And what is your comment or question
today?
Okay. Okay. I'm going to Jill I'm going
to reveal something personal. I I've
never had children and I was very
athletic, extremely athletic and I would
miss my periods and no one mentioned
that I was lacking fats. Nothing. I
thought the lean fantastic athlete and I
would go to gyms. I would put extra
pressure on myself way more even on the
hips legs. And even to this day I have
uh pressure
um they call them pressure um not
varicose veins they call them pressure
veins surface from on my legs as a
result and I've been to an acuptomy
she says these are not varicose veins
this is due through extreme pressure and
the body remembers and I did not even
see like like the body she said
remembers all kinds of trauma from years
ago and like for instance one I was in a
parade where I was a drunk. We walked
for miles and we had to walk with these
big kettle drums and my leg was killing
me and I was 12. I never had any sign of
any injury to my leg until about 15
years ago. All of a sudden, this big ru
surfaces right where that drum was
hitting. And so now I'm going to an
acupuncturist and you won't believe what
they're doing.
She can take little needles and she's
draining
that little where the blood has
coagulated there. And now with the
nutrition and the strength hopefully it
will maintain itself and it won't come
back because otherwise the doctors just
say saline
um and then that's all cosmetic and
super expensive. This is to an
acupuncturist and in 10 minutes she can
like drain a spot. he might have to redo
his spot a little bit. And it's
fascinating, but it's a shame that I
can't never had children. And Dr.
Wallace said many times he was able to
just getting women on the fats, healthy
fats. I never took fats. I don't
remember ever focusing on that carbs. I
would come home after all day at school,
then through the inter mural and
athletic programs. It'd be 7:00 at
night. My mom had already cleaned up the
gym. I had not eaten. I would move on to
cereal, grab a bowl of milk and pour
Captain Crunch, anything to get energy,
to get sugar. I was craving it.
>> Yeah.
>> And I had no idea. And this this was not
till years and years. I mean, I would
say about 10 years ago that I started to
see the nutrition.
I I even started to try to take some
supplements here and there, but it
wasn't enough because I was still so
athletic.
I was running. I would do sit-ups and
miles. And to to never have children,
you can't take bring that back. And I
was seven. I mean, I was about I say I
actually was in my 20s and I was with an
energy specialist. And he's scanning my
body. It was winter. I'm sitting across
from his desk. I'm at his home. And he
goes, "You have some scoliosis."
And I had clothes on. You'd never know.
And he said, "Let me scan your body."
And he goes, "From age zero to five, no
problems. Age seven, and that's when you
enter school." So you think about how if
you're really active and the nutrition
in school, how poor it is, right? And I
thought I was really into gymnastics
again that I would spend hours in gym
even at seven and eight. My parents
would just drop me off.
And so all day I would be just like
jumping, running, doing they would they
would open up those gyms and you had you
had access to balance feeds, everything,
right? And so I had no idea that I
needed that nutrition. My my mom said I
said, "Why did you give us the food that
we had?" And she said, "That's I thought
you wanted." She did didn't know.
And Dr. Wall said that with progesterone
and just giving the nutrition, he he
helped so many women get pregnant. And I
didn't realize this until after
menopause or around menopause. It was
too late.
>> Yeah, it's kind of it's a very tragic
story in
>> Marilyn. Thank you for sharing that.
Wow. Like that that story outlines the
experience of so many young people over
the generations who are active, who are
kinesthetic learners, who are
experiential, who need to move, to need
to be engaged, who are social, who join
activities and join sports, but are not
fueled properly. And ultimately, you're
right, the body, you said a couple lines
that really stood out to me. The body
remembers it does. And that you are now
though, look at the miracle. All these
decades later, you are able to go back
and heal these traumas, these these um
blocks, right? The the lack that was
experienced then and replenish and
rebuild now. Like that you're here to
share that testimonial. I mean, that is
a that's such a gift that in of itself.
And the fact that um doing these sports
is wonderful at the time in so many
ways, but it also becomes addictive. And
that's something else I wanted to point
out because it's like we can't stop
because we get that hit of dopamine by
going after that next win, that next
level, that next improvement. And then
we get the oxytocin through our coaches
and our teammates giving us a pat on the
back, cheering us on. our parents look
at how my child's doing. My child's so
active. My child's so fast. My child and
there's all this oxytocin and dopamine
and serotonin that we get which becomes
in and of itself is typically healthy
but in moderation when it becomes at the
expense of actual self-care and
replenishment like proper eating and
proper supplementing. Um and then it
becomes we're we're kind of like um
we're in a vicious cycle, right? Right.
It was just a cycle of of decline and
not even realizing it.
>> Yeah. And your relationships really
matter. I was with my first husband was
un athletic. Like he was addicted to it.
>> So that didn't help anything. It just it
didn't
>> There you go. Yeah. There you perfect
example. And you would attract each
other because you'd be on that same
page. You have that that same you'd be
like looking for those endorphins,
looking for that challenge. And but
again, this goes to show us that while
activity is important, Doc Wallik taught
us that no professional athlete lives a
long life if they're not supplementing.
They have and many of them obviously
have to leave their sport because of
age, but also because of injury, injury
and lack of healing and full recovery.
And so we we kind of we have this um
piece of paper my mom found recently um
where it's sweating, is it hazardous to
your health? And then realizing that
yes, we need the detoxification of
sweating is helpful, but if we're not,
we're also losing all these essential
nutrients, especially minerals that we
need to replace. And who's
>> even that? Even that just what you're
saying, we would sit in the saunas and
we try to go longer thinking that was
better for you.
>> There are you guys doing exactly and a
lot of sports are played outdoors in the
heat in the summer, so you're sweating
with that, too. That's the outdoor
sauna. And you're potentially going into
a sauna. Like, isn't it amazing? It's we
we're not taught that these things in
moderation with proper replenishment is
a healthy lifestyle. But what we're
talking about here today Yeah. You never
think I'd be here today after what
happened. But like you said, the body
can really heal and it can take a lot of
abuse
>> and you start to see the neglect, but
you don't understand what it is. You
really don't. It's right in front of
you, but you don't see it.
>> But thank you.
>> Well said. Thank you. Great story.
Appreciate you. Thank you.
>> Oh, thank you, Marilyn. And yes, you're
going to be able to use your experience
and you are using your experiences to
help others
not necessarily go down that same road,
>> folks.
Great show today.
>> Thank you. Thank you so much, Jill, um,
for for being on with us, sharing the
testimonial of your sister, sharing the
brain fitness and how so how important
it is when it comes to leadership and
motivation of not just others but
ourselves.
Folks, Jill Helet, go ahead and go to
her website again, sign up for her email
list so you don't miss her next free
webinar and any other additional things
that she has offered. Um, and she does
have course also. So, make sure that you
check out her course and a book that she
and Pharmacist Ben are working on. Can't
wait to be able to uh help promote that
book as well.
And Jill, I know you've got a hard stop,
so if you need to sign off, feel free.
Um, folks, you've been watching Daily
with Doc and Becca, bringing empowering
education
to help equipped you to be able to
choose a better health journey. Not just
nutritionally, physically, but here
we're talking about the brain as well
and how important it is to support the
brain through nutrition.
If you have any questions, please get
back to the person that shared this
program with you as they cared enough
about you to share it, care enough about
them to say thank you. And as you're
listening, if you think of anybody that
would benefit from the information in
any of our programming, please make sure
that you share this program with them.
You can find our channels by going to
YouTube.ailywithdoc.com
or if you like Rumble better,
rumble.withwithdoc.com.
We make it simple. And there's
x.dwithdoc.com.
So on and so forth.
Thank you for joining us. I can't wait
to have you back with us tomorrow. Same
place, same time, 12:00 p.m. Pacific, 1
Mountain, 2 Central, 3 Eastern.
And again, look up in your favorite
browser to find out what time it is in
your time zone. Tomorrow, we're going to
be having Dr. Judy back talking about
epigenetics and nutrition research. So
you don't want to miss that one as well.
Again, dailywithdoc.com is the sponsor
of this program and it's not meant to
take the place of your primary care
physician, nor is it meant to treat,
diagnose, or cure any disease. But
folks, there's so much that you can do.
And if you're interested in learning
more about the four areas of health, how
they're affected by nutrition,
nutritional deficiencies, there is the
Institute of Holistic Health that has a
certified holistic health coach course.
You can get more information about that
by going to coach.dwithdoc.com.
So until next time, bye for now. Thank
you again, Jill.
>> Thank you so much everyone. Great to be
with you. See you next time.
>> Thank you for having or being here with
us.
>> Always a pleasure.
>> Bye.
>> Awesome. Bye for now everybody.
>> [music]
[music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. [music]
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual. Results
vary and may not be typical. We do not
make any claims regarding [music] health
or income. As an empowered individual,
you do have options available. We are
honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics, [music] Dr. Joel
Wallik, Bachelor of Science in Plant and
Soil Sciences, Doctor of Veterary
Medicine, four post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
>> [music]